[Music]  the other night we debuted our first  Conan xxx video entitled one guy two  bulls it was basically Andy eating two  bowls of soup and tonight we've got  another Conan xxx video to show you this  one features a show staff for Suzy sent  tomorrow it's called one girl twenty  pencils fun hello what's your name  Susie Susie thanks for coming and doing  this you're welcome  do you know why you're here today Susie  I do know why are you  I'm here to sharpen some pencils that's  right here's what's going on we have a  lot of pencils that need sharpened you  think how to sharpen all those pencils  for me  I'll try do my best let's get the pencil  sharpener in here we got an electric  pencil sharpener for you you start  anything it's not sharpening keep going  [Laughter]  okay  [Applause]  [Music]  what is that it's a really big pencil do  you like that funding  anyway it's a real sight so go check it  out at conan dot XXX  is the least sexy thing any man has ever  done